When you hear that
statement from the president
not seeking conflict,
that this is clearly in response
to those three American service
who were killed
and then
what we know about the actual st
targets, 125
precision munitions, B-1 bombers
What do you make of this respons
Listen, the administration
I think there's a parallel to th
it handled the war in Ukraine.
Does not want there.
They did not want a direct confl
with Russia.
They're arming
Ukraine to defend itself here.
They want to defend Israel.
They want to keep a lid on tax
on shipping by the Houthi rebels
and, of course, on attacks on U.
personnel in Iraq and Syria.
But they don't want
a direct conflict with Iran,
even though they know
and they say repeatedly
Iran is backing these groups,
arming them.
And these attacks would not be h
without Iran,
regardless of whether they belie
they're directly issuing the ord
and that the fact is
they have a conflict with Iran h
because their interests are
in direct opposition
in a number of places.
And U.S. soldiers have died.
These strikes happen,
as you were showing the pictures
there, as Biden
and his and his wife
and the secretary of defense
were at Dover
receiving the remains of three s
members who died in attack
by Iran backed militias.
So they're already in the confli
with it
and it's already
expanded beyond Gaza, sadly,
on a number of fronts.
So the question is,
does this keep it from expanding
And it's not clear it does.
The U.S.
has responded to militia attacks
service members in recent weeks.
Those attacks have continued.
They've escalated.
You've killed soldiers.
So those answers haven't worked.
This is larger.
But it took a number of days.
You could be certain
the Iranian personnel
went to ground or left.
So they weren't there
when these attacks took place.
They probably hit
a lot of their material as well.
So you have
you already have a question
about the effect of the deterren
We'll only know.
We'll only know over time.
But but it's not a clear cut sol
to something that was already ex
beyond what they wanted.
Yeah,
we've talked about all these eff
to make sure that it doesn't esc
that it doesn't expand,
but it has steadily,
obviously, as you say,
the effort is to make sure
that it doesn't
explode and grow
grow beyond what it is
already beth-center.
This notion that the U.S.
doesn't want direct war with Ira
it is something that they have s
throughout the course of the wee
The Biden White House
tonight making clear
that they are not striking insid
How does the Biden ministration
deter Iran
and tell it essentially
to tell its proxies to knock it
while also making clear that the
want to really take the fight to
Well,
they have said those things out
maybe a little bit too much
from my perspective,
you know, But here,
this is a very fine line
right there, threading a needle
And some of this is informed by
You know, Nick was just saying,
you know, when we struck
Soleimani and I was around
briefing President Trump
during those days,
nothing really happened.
That's I kind of disagree with t
Two days later,
there was this massive missile a
on a U.S. base.
It was only by luck and some for
that U.S.
soldiers didn't get killed from
And two months later,
there was another attack
right in March where two U.S.
servicemen and U.K.
servicemen were killed.
We actually just didn't respond
very much to those attacks
because we wanted to
keep a lid on things.
So this is what every administra
does.
There's nothing special or whate
You're trying to figure out wher
that line is.
I'm kind of worried that
this might not be enough.
And so this is why President
Biden says there,
you know,
there will be more
at a place in time of our choosi
So we're
going to have to see how this un
But there isn't a
thing that you can point to.
That's the dot.
You're going to have
to feel your way around it.
Yeah.
Multi-phased over time
is something they're saying,
but certainly out of the gate
it doesn't appear that there's a
close to something like a strike
on the head of the Quds Force
or the IRGC.
I wanna bring in Colonel Cedric
We're lucky enough
to have a retired Air Force colo
When you look at what was used
today, this B-1B bomber
flown from the United States,
when you look at that long list
of targets that were struck that
initially read out
from that CENTCOM statement,
does anything stand out to you?
Well, I think the big thing here
is that a lot of what is going
on, Alex, is happening in an are
where the intelligence community
the militias are active.
So it's pretty clear
we're focusing on the Euphrates
River Valley,
which has been struck
before by the United. Exactly.
It has been struck before.
They know that, in essence, what
that is a strike of the target.
Now, usually
strikes happen within a cycle of
tasking orders.
But what that really means is
those targets can be struck
at our discretion.
And when they are struck in this
yes, there's a message
that's being sent to Iran,
but also to the proxies.
And if we if they continue to fi
with the American forces
and if they continue to attack t
there can be more attacks like t
So in terms of the targets that
what we're looking at here,
I think is something
that's pretty clear, that
it's command and control, supply
and logistics oriented.
So what they're trying to do
is they're trying to starve them
from their capabilities
and in essence, cut the link fro
to those militia groups.
Now, they're not going
to be completely successful
in doing that
with this one strike,
as extensive as it was.
But it's still a message
that it can be done
and it's a message
that we will use any weapon
at our disposal,
almost any weapon
at our disposal to do this.
You know, a very important borde
right there between Iraq and Syr
Of course, there's a straight
logistics line from Iran
just to the east of there.
I want to get to David Sanger.
He's also with us.
David,
you've said that the response op
for Biden range
from what you've called unsatisf
to highly risky so far
from what we've seen so far.
Where do you think this is on th
Well, somewhere in the middle,
probably leaning
a little more toward unsatisfyin
The risky part of this
would have been to go attack ins
And what I find
interesting about the symbolism
of using the B-1
is that it's a reminder to the I
that if the U.S. decided
it needed to go after
the major nuclear sites
in Iran at Natanz and Fordo,
this is probably the weapon
they would use this and be to us
And so they're making their poin
They know how to reach this
from the continental United Stat
I'm sure that these strikes will
the capability of a lot of the p
but it's not a long term solutio
for cutting them all.
And many of the proxy view
their interests
here is a bit different from Ira
Iran's a major state,
has got a lot of assets to lose.
These militia groups sort of whe
by not folding when the United S
strikes them.
And that's
what we've seen happen with the
who came out of Yemen
and were doing more attacks on s
just yesterday and and today.
So it's not clear to me
that this will deter.
It may well slow them down for a
And I don't know anybody in the
government who thinks that
this is a solution.
It's a sending of a message.
And they think the Iranians,
for the reasons
best phrased, are
probably receiving that message
and trying
to tell the proxies
to back off for a bit.
David, you've written a lot abou
the targeting of Iran when it
through cyber methods.
There is an expectation that per
what is happening today
and in the coming phases of
this is not just kinetic,
not just
military like we're seeing right
with with
with jets dropping bombs, but co
there could also be some cyber t
What do you think the U.S.
is doing on
the cyber front vis
a vis Iran and its proxies right
Well,
the most obvious target for cybe
would be some of their command
and control.
It would be their ability to pro
some of these weapons, including
the drones,
including their missile supplies
But, you know,
cyber takes a lot more time and
If U.S.
Cyber Command
has been inside
the Iranian facilities for some
then they could execute
a simultaneous strike.
But it's not something
you can work up in a week or nec
even a month.
It takes a long time to get acce
Now, Iran's been a target for so
Presumably they know what
some of those accesses are.
That could also be part of the n
I think one of the reasons
that they were using bombers
coming in from the U.S.
is that
they want to preserve
their capabilities in the Medite
in the Red Sea and so forth,
so that
they've got that for a second st
Same thing could be the case for